se retrouver autour d'une tasse de thé
prendre le temps de bavarder avec des
amis des choses simples que ces mamans
qui ont un ou plusieurs enfants porteurs
de handicap ne peuvent que très rarement
se permettre
car avoir un enfant porteur de handicap
c'est faire face à de nombreuses
difficultés souvent les mamans sont
accaparés et non plus le temps pour elle
même c'est pourquoi l'association
famille espoir organise une fois par
mois ces journées maman un rendez vous
bien être spécialement dédié aux mamans
un véritable sas de décompression pour
ces dames qui le temps d'une journée
n'ont qu'une chose à faire prendre soin
d'elle
je m'appelle sylvia je suis la maman
l'artiste anne de trois ans qui atteint
du syndrome de tricheurs collins qui
l'aï les malentendants il a une fin ont
pas lire qui fait que le oui qui
n'arrivent pas à communiquer jusqu'à
maintenant
bah on vit quasiment que pour lui au
début maintenant ça commence à ça va il
grandit donc il va de mieux en mieux
mais c'est vrai qu'au début
24 24 7 jours sur 7 pour lui on n'a pas
forcément le temps quotidien d'aller au
coiffeur ou chez l'esthéticienne quoi
que ce soit alors que là on a un moment
pour nous on se fait choyer ses biens
notre quotidien est tellement lourd par
rapport aux pathologies nos enfants ça
nous fait on va dire une journée off qui
nous permet de nous détendre de vivre
autre chose de partager des moments de
plaisir détente un petit peu parlé plus
avec plusieurs personnes et tout ça
c'est bien
par contre la maladie et les personnes
peu nous écouter peut nous comprendre
aussi parce que mais ils ont dont ils
sont dans la même situation que nous
lassé des parents qui viennent et même
quasiment les mêmes choses que nous qui
ressent la même chose que nous donc
c'est plus facile de partager tout ce
qu'on ressent toujours en vie qu'importe
très content que ce soit à l'hôpital
mama rendez vous qui s'est mal passé on
sait que ils sont là on peut en parler
librement ce projet de l'association
famille espoir vient du vécu ça à bien
notre expérience personnelle à mon mari
et moi parce que nous sommes tous les
deux parents de deux petits champions
avec des besoins spéciaux dont cloyne
pièce qui aura six ans et joshua qui
aura deux enfants qui sont tous les deux
porteurs d'une maladie orpheline dont
qu'on a à me découvrir le quotidien de
barande enfants à besoins spéciaux on a
découvert les va-et-vient à l'hôpital
est prise en charge thérapeutique donc
l'association est née delà de notre vécu
on prend quatre à six mamans d'enfants à
besoins spéciaux qu'on rencontre au
calme soit à l'hôpital tout dépend ou
sur demande et on leur offre un moment
bien n'être donc ça dépend des
professionnels qui sont là aujourd'hui
par exemple si une coiffeuse donc c'est
elles se font coiffer gratuitement et si
elles n'ont pas les moyens de faire
garder leurs enfants on leur propose
l'équipe d'animatrices qui sont là pour
prendre soin du petit bout de chou
pendant qu'elles se font sous tif ne
plus avoir de temps pour soi c'est un
piège dans lequel il est difficile de ne
pas tomber car avoir un enfant porteur
de handicap
c'est aussi une prise en charge quasi
permanente un rythme soutenu qu'il faut
savoir tenir parce qu'on veut tellement
faire évoluer nos enfants vers quelque
chose de positif
2 comment dire on est tellement pris un
hacker on prend tellement à coeur
d'avancé de donner ses soins d'aller
toujours plus loin de les aider à se
dépasser
bacon s'oublie parce que quand on a
rendez-vous
on fait qu'une chose c'est d'essayer
d'arriver à l'heure donc au niveau tenue
vestimentaire on enfile un jean un tee
shirt on s'attache les cheveux et allez
hop on est partis soient certaines
prennent un taxi donc ne sont pas
véhiculés donc ont besoin justement
avoir des moments de trajet d'attentes
soit moi qui suis véhicules et ça
m'arrive de passer une demi-heure à
l'aller pour aller jusqu'à jusqu'aux
soins une demi-heure retour plus le soin
donc gg une matinée de perdue quelque
part donc à travers tout ça
oui on s'oublie puis quand on arrive à
la maison le quotidien d'une maman nous
reprend je veux dire
et puis c'est comme si entre guillemets
qu'on avait des enfants tout petit
autant un enfant grandit évolué devient
comment dire ça devient autonome
nous nos enfants on a besoin de lol de
beaucoup les aider pour arriver une
autonomie on n'y arrive pas toujours
et du coup et ben des moments pour soi
on en a quasiment pas parce qu'on est on
est pris par coeur de donner le
bien-être à notre famille surtout voilà
ici la question du handicap n'est pas un
tabou
les mamans peuvent échanger sans se
soucier du regard des autres
on peut pas dire que dans notre société
on arrive vraiment à échanger avec
l'ensemble de notre famille de gens
qu'on rencontre sur les difficultés
qu'on rencontre et séjours au départ m
qu'on prenne soin de nous au niveau des
fois physique puisque c'est des soins
maquillage c'est des soins esthétiques
aujourd'hui coiffure mais en même temps
soin de ce qu'on a besoin de dire et
d'échangés et ça nous permet parfois
d'échanger sur des sujets variés sur des
difficultés qu'on rencontre avec les
enfants tout simplement
c'est un tramway
pour nous ça va c'est quand on a accepté
26 capes c'est bon après c'est le regard
des autres le fait qu'il n'a pas
d'oreilles et qui va tourner le regard
devant le mât s'est dit vraiment donc
parfois c'est mon mais parfois c'est
lourd c'est moi à part ça le regarde on
fait avec des fois après y'a des jours
ils essaient de remettre des gens un peu
leur place parce que aujourd'hui les
petits et comprend pas mais demain ils
risquent d'être propulsé par tout ça
j'accède mieux la maladie donc ben si je
préfère que les gens viennent vers moi
pour demander pardon à loyal mais sinon
ça peut fois qu'il vient vers moi que
regarder comme ça et des recontres
qu'ordre comme ça après la séance de
coiffure le goûter c'est l'heure du
déjeuner la bonne humeur les rires et
les échanges continuaient autour d'un
repas prendre le temps de faire des
choses agréables pour soi
s'autoriser à prendre du plaisir autant
d'émotions qui sont le bien être à la
base de l'épanouissement tout parent
tout bon parent savent très bien que des
parents qui sont épanouis peuvent
apporter l'amour nécessaires à leur
enfant que si nous mêmes on est rempli
on est bien on pourra apporter je veux
dire qu'on est des enfants déficients ou
pas je veux dire tout parent sait
pertinemment que d'aller courir une
demi-heure ou une heure pour se défouler
au niveau
nervosité au niveau stress de la vie
fait quatre ans revient on n'est pas
nuit on a le sourire jusque là donc
forcément ces journées mamans sont super
parce qu'elle nous permette de tirer le
frein à main qu'on ne serait pas faire
si elles n'existaient pas dans notre
quotidien tout simplement